(upbeat lively music)
- Welcome to episode
three of the Addy Hour.
For any of you who are new listeners,
happy to have you joining in
with this podcast conversation.
Really encourage you also to check out
our first conversations
from the first two episodes.
I think you'll really
enjoy some of the depth
that we were able to jump
into in both of those.
But for today's episode,
really excited to welcome two guests
and we're gonna be discussing
topics related to stigma,
mental health disparities,
youth, and suicide prevention.
So clearly some heavy topics
but some important topics that
we need to discuss as well.
And I'm really honored to
welcome today's two guests.
The first is Dr. Alfiee Breland-Noble.
Dr. Alfiee is an
internationally recognized
mental health expert,
scientist, author, speaker,
and media contributor.
She's also the founder
of the AAKOMA Project
and the host of the
Couched in Color podcast
where she focuses on mental
health and BIPOC youth
and more generally in
marginalized communities
and in marginalized youth as well.
One of the things I really
admire about Dr. Alfiee
is her effectiveness and skill
in translating complex scientific concepts
into everyday language.
I think that's a rare
commodity, unfortunately,
but I'm really thrilled that
she's so skilled in that
and that she's willing to jump
in to today's conversation.
So thanks for being here.
- Of course, my pleasure.
- Our second guest is Doug Middleton.
Doug, I almost gave you a doctor title.
It just kinda flowed out.
Maybe I'm speaking that
into the future, who knows.
- There you go.
(laughs)
- I'm a degree away so I
got a little work to do.
- That works, that works.
Doug is an NFL safety for
the Jacksonville Jaguars,
and he's also a mental health advocate
who is all about action.
As the founder of the Dream
the Impossible Foundation,
Doug has been bringing
mental health awareness
to communities, to high
schools, to universities,
and specifically to the
African American community.
So he's used his platform
to really address things
like mental health risk factors
to talk about access to
mental health services,
and he also has a large
emphasis on youth development.
He's partnered with many different groups,
one of which is the National
Alliance on Mental Illness.
So I'm thrilled to welcome
Dr. Doug to the program today.
It's gonna keep rolling--
- Appreciate it.
(laughs)
- We speak those things into the future.
- Amen.
- And to be clear, I
mean, some of the work
that you're doing already is
so impactful, both of you.
So I'm just honored that
you're both willing to jump
into this conversation.
- Appreciate you having us.
- So I thought it would also
be helpful for our listeners,
for any who might not be
familiar with you all,
just to get to know you a little bit
and to just talk about
where we are as a society
at this moment.
Clearly, it's been a challenging
few weeks in the country
especially with the tragic
shootings in Atlanta,
and then of course following up
with tragic students in Boulder.
And so in a lot of ways,
I mean, we're all still
going through, as a society,
a level of loss and mourning
around those two issues,
and especially whenever
there's a mass shooting
and all the trauma that
can come from that,
but all the different emotions that come
in time with that as well.
So I thought, just to be
honest and have people,
have both of you just share
how you're doing right now
in the midst of everything
that's going on,
so, Dr. Alfiee, we can go
ahead and start with you.
- Okay, sure.
So a couple of things.
One thing I think is a
little odd, I'll start there,
for me in terms of my response.
And I'm sure I'm not alone, but I think,
because I am a black woman,
the response that I have had
to the two different shootings
really centers around this idea
of how do we respond to
people who commit these acts
when these people are of
different racial, ethnic groups.
And so the first thing
I heard, first of all,
Muslim is not a race, right?
Islam is a religion.
And to hear people talk about
the second shooter in
that context, it upset me.
Number one.
And number two, I look at
the excuses that people may,
for the white male who
shot those four people
including mostly Asian women,
he was having, like, I
literally watched that.
And, like, it makes me teary
just sitting here thinking about it,
but I was so, I was
livid when I watched it.
And I think I even tweeted
and put it on social media.
Like, this is how you describe people?
He had a bad day.
We all have bad days.
All three of us have had bad days.
It's never occurred to
me to go pick up a gun
and shoot somebody because
I was having a bad day.
So that really hurt me because
I have a close girlfriends
who are Asian American,
my goddaughter is Asian
American and Filipino
and they're just people in my life
who I know are deeply impacted by it.
So I hurt because they hurt.
And then on top of all
of that, being black,
we still going through it.
It's like every day it's somethin' else
and we always going through it.
So I think it's all of
those things together.
It's just like the
perfect storm of awfulness
on top of the pandemic and
being stuck in the house.
And so all of those things together
it's just made it really heavy.
So I've had to work really hard
to keep my own mental health in check
and just kinda keep myself grounded.
So I believe in meditation.
I've meditated before we
even started recording.
So that's what it's been for me,
just really trying to pay attention.
'Cause we're healers, all three of us,
the work that we do is in healing.
And sometimes when you're a
healer, you're giving so much.
I think we can forget to take care of,
we gotta heal ourselves too.
So that's been my thing,
trying to pay attention
and be attending to that and be mindful
of how I need to take care of myself.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, those are also important.
All those pieces.
I mean, like you mentioned too,
this is not happening in isolation.
Everything we've already
experienced in the last year.
And then obviously for us as black people,
all the things that we
experienced on a daily basis
trying to walk through.
I mean, I think there's a level of empathy
that we're able to have
in these situations.
Not to say that others
can't have that too,
but just some of those common experiences.
And then to see, like you said,
how some of that can be dismissed
and the focus just shifts
away from the victims
instead of where it needs to be.
So I appreciate your
honesty and sharing that.
What about you, Doug?
- I think, for me, one of the things
that I've been focused on the most over,
I mean, really since COVID,
really start to happen
is really controlling what
I give myself access to.
I think that's something I've
really focused very hard on.
Because, I mean, you can
turn on the news every day
and see something horrible
going on in your community,
you could see something horrible
going on the other side of the country.
And yes, I'm emotionally
affected by the shootings
that's taken place in
Colorado and Georgia.
But to not mention that,
I mean, African Americans
have been suffering a
lot this year with COVID.
So I definitely don't
agree with any things
that's going on in this country,
but at the same time I
have to start to control
some of the things that I see.
Because, I mean, it's every
day that there's something.
That every day that is
something that's going on,
that somebody is being killed
and somebody is being hurt.
And like you said, as healers,
it's hard to not wanna feel like
we wanna do something to change that.
I even flashed back to when George Floyd,
during that incident and how
I felt when I was on vacation.
I was on vacation with my fiance
and we like logged on to Twitter
and just seeing all the videos and stuff
and like every time you looked
it was just something there
and it was like we couldn't
even really enjoy our vacation.
We really just left and went home
because we felt like
we had to do something.
And that moment right
there kinda showed me
how I have to control
the things that I see
and how much it impacts my
own personal mental health.
So for me, I see those things
and I try to do the
best that I can to heal
and make a difference.
But at the same time there's
only so much that I could do.
I can't go out there and
change gun control policies.
change the way people feel
about other ethnicities.
So it's tough.
And I think the best thing that I can do
is focus on the things that
I can change from day to day.
I mean, even things as small as,
one of my tenant's dog died
and that was the only thing she had
when she moved over here.
She had a tough breakup
and she moved on the other
side of the country after it
and all the things she's had is her dog
for the last 12 years.
And people might say, oh,
that's just something small.
Well, I mean, that's
something huge to her,
that's something huge to me.
So it's just so much going on.
You really have to control
what you put into your mind
and what you give yourself access to.
- Yeah, that's so true.
And like you said, it's
that balancing act too.
'Cause if you're empathetic
and being the healer,
you still wanna be able to reach out.
But if you're tank is completely empty,
then you're not gonna be
any good for anybody else.
And Dr. Alfiee, I know you've
talked about that too a lot
in terms of the same
thing Doug has mentioned,
how much we consume, like where
do we set those boundaries
to be informed but not just
be so overwhelmed with it
that it just drags us down to a place
that we can't heal others.
And then at the same time,
I mean, we're healers
but we also need to be healed.
So both things are
happening at the same time.
It's not like we're always
in that place of full healing
and going out to help others.
We're still, like you said, Doug,
kind of going through it ourselves too.
So definitely balancing that.
- Yeah.
For me, I know like, if I see too much,
sometimes I try to help,
but if I see too much and
something is going on,
I just shut down because it's like,
well, is my impact even
making a difference?
Am I even like creating change?
I was like, there's just so much going on
that I'll never be able to help people.
So that's kinda why I
personally have to filter
some of the things that I see,
because it prevents me from shutting down
and kinda just like going into reserve
where I realize that there's
nothing really I can do.
The worst gonna be the way it is.
- Yeah, but what I like
about what Doug is saying
is, as a person who's a
mental health advocate,
the recognition that you do have to,
I phrase it as curating your news.
So you have to be careful,
just like Doug said, I
can't say it any better,
about how much you consume,
you also wanna be careful
about what you consume, right?
So I tell people, I
still haven't to this day
watched the video of George Floyd.
And the closest I came was, I was blessed,
I had an opportunity to do CNN,
like, literally, I think it was that week
and they showed it.
And I like literally wouldn't look.
I just didn't look at the screen
while they were showing it.
'Cause I don't wanna see that.
'Cause I know me, I'm anxious.
And so that would be
stuck in my brain forever.
Once you see it, you can't unsee it.
And then people will say stuff like,
yeah, but you ain't woke if you don't,
you ain't down for that.
I'm like, nah, man, I'm more
woke if I take care of myself.
'Cause if I take care of
myself on the front end,
I can have a longer opportunity
and more opportunity to go have an impact.
But if I'm like riddled and
like curled up in a ball
'cause of how awful it was
and thinking about his little girl,
and I'm just, like all of that,
like how many people are
hurt because of that?
And it was so senseless.
That on a dollar bill or something.
So I have to be careful
about the ways in which I consume it.
And so I would just add to what Doug said.
I tell people, you can't
watch that stuff all the time.
If you wanna be informed,
sometimes you need to just
go to a website and read or pick up,
anybody who does use the newspaper,
pick up a piece of paper and read
'cause then you have a
little bit more control.
But just sitting and watching,
I'm with him, I can't do it.
- Yeah, exactly right.
- Yeah, that's important.
So I mean, all these
topics are so, so critical
and I'm curious how, because both of you
have so much work that you do with youth.
So if you could actually
share a little bit
about your journey into that work
and then also talk about
some of these principles
and how those come together,
like how do you pass on
some of this knowledge
to the youth that you're working with?
- Okay.
Such gentleman, I love it.
Just gentleman.
I just eat it up.
I need to get my son in here and like,
this is how you treat women.
But I thank you for that, Doug.
So the AAKOMA Project, long story short,
really came out of a
research lab that I had.
I founded it in 1999, when I was three.
I'm just kidding.
And so when I founded the lab,
we were really all about
trying to understand
how do we encourage
black youth specifically?
My thing was black kids.
So AAKOMA started as the acronym
African American Knowledge Optimized
for Mindfully Healthy Adolescents.
So my whole thing was just,
what can we do to help
our young black kids build their brains,
build their, not just resilience,
but learn how to take care
of themselves emotionally.
Because back then, that was the '90s,
nobody was talking about it
like we talk about it now.
It just was not a thing.
And as a black person
with my white colleagues,
God bless them, but my white
colleagues would say things
like, well, how is depression or anxiety
any different in black kids
than it is in anybody else?
And my thing will be,
well, we don't have to
unpack that a little bit
because black children specifically
and other kids of color
have to deal with racism
and discrimination.
So for one, that's a huge difference,
not to mention when you
layer on multiple identities
like gender identities
or sexual orientation
or whether people are
gender conforming or not,
and so that was really where we started.
How do we get kids into care?
At the time, I said, it's not
my job to fix what's provided
once they get into care,
once they get in their
bottom in that chair.
Now, it is some of that too,
but we gotta get them in
because they can't benefit
from the treatments
if nobody's going, right?
So that's where we started.
Over time we evolved.
And then in 2019, 20 years later,
we became a full-fledged 501c3.
So I stopped being a traditional academic.
Less people have heard me tell this story,
because it was, in my
experience, I'm an NF1,
it was too restrictive.
And so I couldn't do the
kinds of things I wanted to do
like name racial trauma as an
issue that impacts black kids
and kids of color and study that.
And so I said, okay, I gotta
do something different.
So I left traditional academia
after 17, 18 years in
departments of psychiatry
and we turned AAKOMA into a nonprofit.
And now, what AAKOMA is
focused on is three things.
We raise consciousness, right?
So we wanna raise people's awareness
about these issues of mental health,
just like Doug and what he does.
We empower people.
'Cause y'all we know, we know we look like
and we know how many of
us are never going to see
a mental health professional.
We try to change that,
but we know, as of today,
there are many who are never gonna go.
And so we want people to
have tools they can use
in the interim.
So if they never get in
your office, Dr. Addy,
or if they never get
with somebody like Doug
who can get them into,
direct them to care,
we want 'em to be able to do something
to take care of themselves.
And the most important
thing I feel like we do
is we work to change the system.
We work to shift the system.
We want the system to be something,
the mental health system in particular,
to be a place where black people
and people of color feel welcome.
Where when you walk in,
if you speak Tagalog,
like grew up in a very
heavily Filipino community
in Virginia Beach, Virginia,
close to Pharrell Williams and Timberland,
we all live within like a seven,
eight mile radius of each other.
And so in that community the populations
that were the biggest that
were of color were Filipino,
not just Asian, it was Filipinos
because of the Navy and black folks,
and so we wanna make sure
that the system is set up
such that if I speak Tagalog,
I should be able to find a
provider who speaks Tagalog,
at least enough to help me do some therapy
or who knows enough
about different cultures.
You can't know everything there is to know
about every culture.
That's impossible.
But you can be open, right?
I can learn how to say,
"Salamat" and thank you,
which is thank you in Tagalog.
Or I can learn how to say, "Mahal kita,"
which is I love you in Tagalog,
because that little bit of phrasing
is gonna let somebody
know that I see them.
And to me, that's the
most important thing.
We need systems that allow
our people to feel seen,
to feel valued, and to feel heard.
So that's what we're about at AAKOMA.
And we're all about research
and outreach in those areas.
- That's so good.
- I love it.
For me, how I got into this space
and kind of the work that I'm doing,
one of my best friends, my
best friends since age six,
AJ Morrison, we lived on
the same street together
in Winston-Salem, where I grew up at,
and went to high school together.
And as we went to college,
our paths began to change a little bit
and AJ started to suffer
from severe depression.
During that time, my mom had
already had a lot of history
in the mental health space
and my brother was starting to transition
and getting that space.
Right now, he's a behavioral
health crisis counselor.
But there were certain
resources that AJ needed
that we didn't really have access to
or we really didn't know what was,
what would will work for him.
And I think that's, just to go
off on a tangent real quick,
I think that's what scares people away
from going to see people and get help,
is like they think like
the first counselor
or the therapist that you
see is supposed to work
and sometimes it takes maybe seeing
four or five different
therapists or counselors
before you find some effective therapy.
Same as with medicine.
I think that was one of
the issues that he had.
So just a learning lesson
from his situation for me.
He saw a therapist, he
was on a specific medicine
but that wasn't the
correct medicine for him.
Maybe he had needed to try
two or three more things,
but at the time we weren't really aware.
And since that was four years ago
and since that time
I've learned a lot more
about mental health and
about effective therapy
and effective medicine.
So since that time, a couple months later,
fast forward today, AJ
suffered a death by suicide.
And then I spoke at his funeral
and spoke about mental
health in African community.
It was all pretty much all
African Americans there.
And I spoke about
depression, anxiety, trauma,
and the things that AJ was going through
and how you can pair up therapy
and going to see somebody
and there's professionals in this space
and I've tried to do all that.
And immediately after
I got out the pulpit,
the pastor caught up and he said,
hey, like, that all sounds good,
but you just need to pray about it
and bring all your burdens to the Lord
and He take care all that.
And that is what really
made me get into this space.
Because right after that,
there was a ton of people that
came up to me and were like,
hey, I'm suffering too.
Like, I need help.
Like, what resources are out there?
And it's like, in our community,
the stigma is so strong.
It's even the same way with my grandma.
Like, how she was raised
and how past generations were raised,
as like we look up so much
to our pastors and religion.
And I'm a big believer.
I'm a huge Christian.
But I was always taught, from my mom,
that it's prayer plus therapy
or prayer or prayer plus.
It's not just one thing and other.
Like, I wouldn't put
all these professionals
or these experts on this earth
if it was just only something
that you could take to God.
So that's how I kinda got
into the mental health space
and then I wanna just make a difference
in the African American community.
And then after I had a few
seasoned injuries in the NFL,
I started to experience
my own mental health.
Mental health, I guess,
I don't know, situations
and that's when I really went
to focus on student athletes,
professional athletes and
helping them empower themselves
to careers outside of football,
being able to feel purposeful
through their transition
from the game into whatever they do next.
And that's kinda where we
are now, what I'm doing.
My foundation now is just working
with African American athletes
at primarily white institutions
and just helping them empower themselves
and figure out how to leverage
the environments that they're in
to lead to success after
they're done playing the sport.
So yeah, that's pretty
much the short spiel.
And then I don't wanna go too
long into it, but that's it.
- That's so good.
Definitely appreciate
your passion in that.
And I mean, one thing,
the thing that kinda cuts
across both of what you're talking about
is just that theme of being seen.
Like making sure, one,
that people are seeing
in the first place and
that they know what tools
are available at their disposal.
'Cause like you said, the prayer,
it doesn't remove the prayer,
but we also have all these
tools that God's provided,
all the expertise that
we've been able to develop
through neuroscience,
psychology, psychiatry,
therapy, social work.
There's no need to ignore all that
once they're right there from us.
But Dr. Alfiee, your point too about,
I mean, that could be a
whole another conversation
if we talk about where the stigma started
and why we don't access those services.
But I mean, all those things
are part of the conversation.
So I'm deeply appreciative
of both the efforts
that both of you done to really make sure
that folks are seen and that they know
that there are options in that way.
Just elaborate on that a little bit.
Like, what have you seen
that's been effective,
either one of you, in terms of making sure
that people are seen and
helping people kinda transition
to taking advantage of the resources?
- One of the things that I use,
and with a lot of college
and high school athletes
or professional athletes,
is group therapy.
Group therapy has been a
very effective method for us.
And one of the ways that I
mean about group therapy,
so we will bring maybe three,
four counselors in there
and then we'll have everybody
sit around in a circle
and we pretty much just share
like some of the things that,
some of the experiences
that these athletes
may be having on campus.
And the crazy thing about it
is a lot of these athletes
are suffering alone,
are suffering in silence
and there's so many
people that's in the room
or their colleagues or other
athletes that can help them
that's suffering the same way.
And so that's one thing I
really help them notice,
is that the fact of like,
hey, you're suffering,
like, you need to reach out.
Like, if you reach out, chances are,
like the person across from
you or one of your teammates
are probably suffering
from the same thing.
So, I mean, it was even things like, hey,
like I'm the only black
student in my class.
Hey, like, I'm six hours away from home.
Hey, I'm getting all these looks
by people with other race on campus.
Like, I don't know how to
even conversate with people
with other race.
And those things, they were all suffered
from similar experiences.
So it was like, once we
found a way to connect them
and really share the experiences together.
A year later, they much
improved and a lot of progress.
So that's one of the effective ways.
And of course, anytime you
talk about changing the stigma
is people wanna identify
people that others look up to
and that way that you
can break down the stigma
and that way that people don't
see it as something that,
oh, these people don't do
that, so why would I do it?
So that's been an effective way.
But yeah, I mean, those are
just two points I will say.
- Yeah, that's really good.
What I like about what Doug is sharing
is definitely what shows up
in the research literature.
And that is normalizing
it by showing people,
reflecting people, giving people mirrors.
So when they bring in multiple counselors
or they bring in multiple
people who are of color, right,
what you're doing is normalizing
for these young people.
There are people out there
who look just like you, right,
or look like your cousin or
your people in them, right,
who do this work.
And so those people it's
not always a perfect match,
but they may be more likely to understand
what your individual
personalized experiences are.
Because there's
universality to this issue,
with this idea of,
let's just keep it real,
being black at a predominantly
white institution.
I went to three, right?
My undergrad is from Howard.
So that was heaven for four years.
And then I dove out there into
some of these other spaces
and it won't so heaven, right?
It's kind of the opposite.
And so even little day-to-day stuff,
like we talk about microaggressions,
if you're a athlete and
everybody knows who you are,
that compounds it, right?
'Cause everybody knows
who the athletes are,
especially if you go to a PWI,
like one of my degrees is from Wisconsin,
there was like 12 black people there.
And of them 12, 10 of 'em was athletes.
And if you weren't an athlete,
people assumed you were an athlete
because they had no conceptualization
that black people can go to college
doing something other than,
ain't nothing wrong with sports.
Like I said, my brother
played college ball,
but that's not the only way
that black people go to college.
So my spouse, whom I met at
Wisconsin, interestingly enough,
was there getting a PhD in math
and he's kind of a build, a heavy dude
and the people were like,
yeah, you play for the football team?
He was like, no, I'm here
getting a PhD in math.
And they would look at them.
They were like, right?
They thought they were
getting pranked or something.
And so that kind of stuff,
you can only have that conversation
with somebody who understands
what that feels like.
So, no, I might not, as a
mental health professional,
understand what it feels like
to be an athlete in that space, right?
But I do understand what it feels like
if you don't know the black
girl in the class, right?
And any time a conversation
comes up around,
anything related to race,
everybody like this, right?
- That's right.
- Like, I don't have all the
answers for everybody, right?
That's not what I'm here for.
And so what he speaks to is this idea
of how do you normalize this concept
of talking to people about
what's going on with you.
Stop internalizing it and holding on to it
and thinking that you have
to fix it all by yourself.
So that, and that's in the literature,
that's what we have to do with
our young people of color.
Other things that I find are helpful
are also echoing what Doug said,
which is people need to see somebody,
I think young people in particular,
who's prominent, who has fame,
whom they look up to and admire;
I think often that helps because
it helps young people see
not only are they not alone,
but your circumstances alone don't dictate
whether or not you're struggling
with something psychologically, right?
So having money and fame and
fortune and being in the league
that don't protect you
from mental illness, right?
People struggle.
And so I think that's key.
I think some of the other
things that we found
from our research with AAKOMA
is it's not just about racial matching.
It is about this idea, and I
know you know this, Dr. Addy,
cultural competence.
So if you go see somebody
and you feel like
they're not even trying
to understand who you are,
you gonna vote with your feet.
You're just gonna leave, right?
So if you go in, I'm a chocolate girl
and I started talking about
light skin and dark skin,
they look at me, oh, but I
thought all y'all was black.
True story.
Like, nah, fam, that's
not how it works, right?
And so I'mma need you to like
have a little bit more
knowledge about this stuff.
And so that's important as well.
I think it's also important that we test
the interventions that we use,
the way that we share,
provide psychotherapy.
So I heard you speak too,
doctor, neuroscience, right?
So we have neuroscience,
we have psychiatry,
we have psychology, we have social work,
you have nurse practitioners,
making sure that what we provide
is something that has been
evaluated and assessed
as relevant for the
populations we serve, right?
People want to know that like we assume
people don't have that
much knowledge or interest.
Sure, they do.
I wanna know what is this
stuff you're giving to me,
why are you giving it to me,
and how does it help people
who look like me, right?
So that's important too.
And then the final thing that I will say,
just as an example, there are many others,
is finding the spaces
where people already are.
Again, this is full circle
'cause this goes back
to what Doug was saying
in the beginning.
You bring the care to the people.
Don't always ask the
people to go to the care
because it's stigmatized.
So if they're stigmatized,
you should assume
I ain't trying to come
up in there where you at.
So if you bring it to me,
maybe I'll look at it
a little differently.
And so one of the things that we do,
this book in my background
talks about it too,
one approach is we do work with churches.
So we have to talk with
pastors about please,
just what you said, Doug.
I've heard that myself.
Don't get up in that pulpit
and say stuff like that.
Here's another way you can frame it.
Or just don't say anything about it.
If you don't believe in
it, don't say anything
because people are watching you.
And if they hear you, as the
pastor, say, we'll do that,
you just need to pray, right?
Jesus is your doctor.
If they hear you say that,
that's what they're gonna think.
And so that faith-based
mental health promotion
and finding other ways to
go where the people are,
bringing the group therapy
to the young people
those are all super
effective ways, I think,
to get us into care.
- I think just to add on a
couple of points you said,
'cause like I was, definitely,
you talked about the athlete thing.
Because I mean, you sound
like, you speak and sound like
you were sitting right
in the conversations
that I had with student athletes.
So that was the biggest thing that I had
when I was in college, the
biggest issue that I had
going to Appalachian State.
I think it's like 4%
African American there.
It's like no matter if
you got a hoodie on,
it says you played football
or anything at all,
like people are gonna look at you and say,
hey, like, don't you play football?
I'm like, how do you even know that?
Like, you can't think of my
name, you can't think anything.
But you just think because
I'm a black man on this campus
like I have to play some type of sport.
And that just really stood out
because like all the
athletes we were talking to
they feel exactly like that.
And the cultural competence thing,
I think that's a huge point.
Because I did an event for Super Bowl
with other like NFL athletes
and they were talking about mental health
and somebody comes in and asks us,
like, how can somebody within,
from a different background
or race or ethnicity
really, I guess, be a
counselor or a therapist
to somebody with a different race,
and what are you looking
for when you reach out for,
when you're trying to get help
and somebody that doesn't look like you,
and I think that's a great
point, cultural competence,
is being able to understand
the issues that the race may have
that you may not really know
no much about in the beginning.
- Yeah, and you can't
be afraid of it, right?
So if the brothers show up,
like one of the things
that always stood out to me
was I remember watching
Brandon Marshall story.
And then when they got to the part
where they show the
person who diagnosed him
was an older white guy.
And I thought to myself,
it would have been,
not there's anything wrong with it,
but it would've been so nice
for him to have been paired with somebody
from his background, right,
to sorta talk him through.
This is how, what you, BPD might show up
as somebody who looks like you.
Now, I'm not saying the
white guy didn't know that.
I can guess, but I'm not saying he did it.
So I just think it's important
that we have a diversity
of people available
to brothers and sisters so
that they have choices, right?
And just like Doug said,
if you got to go to three or four people
to find that person who's
gonna understand you
and with whom you have a connection,
we gotta keep encouraging
people to keep looking.
If that first one don't work,
you shop like you shopping for some shoes.
So you a sneaker head,
you gonna keep looking,
keep looking and shopping
for those providers as well.
So I'm just glad he brought
that point up, though,
about with our athletes.
They need people who look like them too.
So we have to press a little bit
for some of these
professional associations,
go find some black and brown people
to bring into these teams
to help these young people
because they need people
they can relate to
without having to explain everything
'cause that gets tiring.
- Yeah, you're exactly right.
You're both exactly right.
'Cause you can't just have that.
You can't have all the onus be
on the person who's coming to therapy.
Like, they don't need to have to bring,
they shouldn't be trying
to teach the provider
about their situation.
Especially if someone's struggling.
There's already too much going on there.
So, I mean, it's so
important in so many ways.
And it cuts across everything too.
So Dr. Alfiee, as you mentioned,
I mean, for me as a neuroscientist,
it cuts across that to how
are we asking those questions
and are we taking all those
things into consideration,
or are we kind of fitting
people into one box
and saying, this is just the way it is.
And then even if we're looking
at a specific mental health challenge,
are we not even taking into account
some of the other factors
that could contribute to that?
So I think both of these,
all the points that you all raised
are so vital and important.
And a big piece of that too is just,
I mean, people have said
this in other settings too,
but when we're trying to help
people get access to resources
or someone who will care
for them, it's a matter of
are those people actually
listening to your story
or are they just putting
you in a box and saying,
this is what I think you are dealing with,
without even hearing
where you're coming from.
And I mean, that ties into
the cultural competency too.
But that happens so often.
- No, that's right.
When you said it, the
first thing I thought
is they see Doug on
campus, Appalachian State,
we know where Appalachian State is.
They're like, yeah, athletes, right?
And yeah, he is, but you
don't know me like that.
You don't know what I'm here for.
I could be here getting a
PhD in neuroscience, right,
like Dr. Addy, so yeah.
And how othering that is, right?
When you make those assumptions,
you make people feel like the other.
Because the idea is
everybody here looks like,
if I'm white, everybody
here looks like me.
So anybody who doesn't look like me,
oh, the only way I can
conceive of you being here
is you have to be an athlete
on a scholarship, right?
And that's hurtful because
we know, internally,
as the person on the receiving end,
we know that's what people think, right?
And we don't wanna live like that.
So that stuff weighs on your psyche
in addition to looking around.
And as we used to say, my
family's from Mississippi,
you the fly in the buttermilk.
I don't wanna be the
fly in the buttermilk.
That ain't comfortable.
That's not fun.
So when you said that, Dr. Addy,
it just made me think
it's that othering piece
that I think can be really hard
and make it really difficult
and challenging for people.
- I think one thing that's
great that you're both doing
is you're building community too.
I mean, Doug, even when
you were talking about
the group therapy.
Like, that's given people community.
They're coming out of isolation.
Like, oh, that person's dealing
with the same thing that I'm dealing with.
But if nobody voices it,
then no one hears that.
And you're all going back
to the neuroscience too.
I mean, there's so much evidence
about how community
actually shapes our brains
and makes it easier for us to deal
with some of these
mental health challenges.
So, I mean, you're both
tapping into that already.
- I love it.
- You got the science to
support it too, I take it.
- Okay, okay, I feel smart today.
Thank you, thank you.
I take it.
- Yeah, bring it on.
I'm learning from both of you too.
(laughs)
On that note, I was
gonna have you both share
a little bit too about
what have you learned
from the young people
that you've worked with?
'Cause I know this is a two-way street.
I mean, you're bringing
obviously a lot of knowledge
and information to them,
but I would imagine that there's
things that you take away
that they teach you as well.
- Yeah.
So for me, I think it's kind of easy.
A couple of things.
One is young people are
more eager to engage
and invest in this space
than we give them credit for.
Two, they have loads of ideas
if we just listen to
them without judgment.
Just listen to 'em, right?
Not every idea is gonna be perfect,
but not every idea we present as adults
is perfect for them either.
Three, I feel like
they're eager to partner
if they're asked in the right way.
So we kinda talked about that
a little bit when we started.
If you ask nicely and if you ask
and then be quiet and listen,
they will talk to you.
I think too often what young people,
what we've learned from
our research is that
we as adults will ask.
But then as soon as we finished asking,
we're answering for them.
We don't give them an opportunity
to express themselves.
So it's this idea of, I
call it active listening.
So first, I have to close my mouth, right,
and I love to talk, so I have to work on,
I just kinda sit on my
hands, close my mouth
after I ask the question and listen.
And you're listening not as
you're crafting an answer,
you're listening to take in
and receive what the
young people are saying.
So I'm learning how to listen from them.
And then the final thing I would say
is I'm learning how to
be more unapologetic.
Like, if nothing, I'm telling you,
the younger millennials and Gen Z
ain't apologizing for being black
or being brown or being
queer or whatever it is.
And I have really truly learned
to stop apologizing for who I am
and just to like own it and inherit it
and inhabit it and stand in it.
And so that's been really powerful for me
to keep going, right, because
there's so many ways in which,
I'm going back to my
experiences as an academic,
people were like, yeah, but yeah,
we already know how to treat depression,
we already know how to treat anxiety.
And I'm thinking, but if you did,
we wouldn't have these health disparities,
we wouldn't have these
differences in who accesses care,
we wouldn't have greater attrition
or drop-off rates when people are black
if you really knew what you were doing.
So clearly, you don't have the answers.
So what I'm learning is to not apologize
for what it is that I wanna study
because these young people don't
apologize for who they are.
So they teach me in those ways too.
So that's not exactly the
answer to the question,
but that is what I'm learning
from the young people.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's it.
- By golly, that's a great answer.
Because like that's
actually the same thing
that I'm learning from them.
This generation is so resilient.
I mean, I keep going back to
this George Floyd situation.
But if you look at all the protests
and everything that was going on
and like all this was kind
of led by young people.
Those are the ones that they're
learning how to strategize
and mobilize and they know how to,
like even, a lot of the
African American students
on our campus at App State,
they had a whole list of
demands that they wanted.
I mean, they don't take no for an answer.
And I think that's kinda
what I'm learning for 'em,
is like how hard and how
passionate they will work
to get what they feel is right
and how they're not gonna accept the world
being the same way that it is.
So, yeah, that's what
I'm learning from them.
- Yeah, I agree with both of you.
I mean, in some ways it's humbling too.
I mean, even looking at this podcast.
10 plus years into my career.
I'm seeing those that are coming up
doing stuff like this from the get-go
even while they're still training.
I can imagine.
So just the level of effort.
And like you said, just
knowing who they are
and saying we're not gonna
take no for an answer
and really just jumping in
and making an impact early on.
It's inspiring in a lot of ways.
So to pivot just a little bit
'cause I know we wanted
to still touch on it
'cause both of you have done aspects
around suicide prevention as well.
I mean, obviously it's not light
topic, it's not easy topic,
but it's again, the same thing
where I feel like there's so
much stigma associated with it
that oftentimes in so many circles
it just doesn't get talked
about and it just gets ignored
so people are kinda left to their own,
whatever concept they have about it.
So I just wanted to ask both of you
like what you've seen in
terms of trying to move
the needle on that and
really breaking that stigma
so that people can get to a place
of really talking about it.
And I guess we can start
just misconceptions
that you've both noticed in your work
that people have around
suicide and suicide prevention.
- I guess one thing
that I could talk about,
just a quick little shout out.
So one of my colleagues
that's in this space,
her name is Fonda Bryant,
but she uses this
question, persuade, refer,
the QPR training.
That's a huge thing that she loves to do.
And it's made it a really
easy way to like kinda
give people a few steps
that way they can help
learn how to prevent suicide.
That's one way that some of
the education has taken place.
And I guess the misconceptions is that
I know a lot of people would
think that when they commit,
when they suffer a death by suicide
that the pain is gonna end,
like that is all gonna go away
and then they'll just
be able to start over.
And that's not really the case.
They have a short-term problem,
but they're trying to fix it
with a long-term solution.
And I think that's the
misconception around it.
I mean, that's kinda all I
really had to say about it
because I still struggle
with trying to find
some of the things that
I've could have done better
with my best friend's life
and some of the ways I
could've provided him
with more steps or more
access to resources
that that way suicide
wasn't really an option.
- Yeah, and I know
that's not an easy topic
so definitely wanna just acknowledge that
and appreciate you being willing to go,
go to that place as well.
'Cause I think that empowers
a lot of people too,
just as we continue to break
through those misconceptions.
And I know that your foundations,
like Legacy Foundation in a
lot of ways for AJ's life.
So definitely appreciate
the way that you're continuing to do that.
How about you, Dr. Alfiee?
- Yeah, so first, I wanna just quickly,
I meant to do at the front
end a whole space for Doug
and the loss of your
friend, 'cause that's a lot.
It's a lot to carry.
And like Dr. Addy, appreciate
you for being vocal and open
and taking action to try to
do something in his honor.
And the other thing I'll
say, now this is the auntie,
I'm sorry, this is the auntie in me.
So it's gonna come out.
But I think it's important
for the survivors,
the ones who are still here, to understand
that when a person is
determined to complete a suicide
it's difficult for us to stop them.
But I think the key is when
they're determined, right,
not everybody, not even most people,
are determined to complete it.
I think what I've learned in
terms of suicide prevention
is that people wanna stop the pain.
They don't really wanna die, right?
I do not believe that anybody,
almost anybody who dies by
suicide that the goal is to die.
The goal is to stop the pain.
And just like you said, Doug,
it's a permanent solution
to what often is a temporary problem.
But sometimes a temporary
goes on too long for people
and they just don't see any other way out.
So what I've learned
about suicide prevention
is that being silent about it,
about these are people's
experiences, that is not helpful
especially for those of us
from underserved communities
or people of color or
black folks in particular.
I've also learned that
it's not a bad thing
to talk about it.
It's not a bad thing to ask the question.
You do not plant the
idea in somebody's head
when you ask them if
they're feeling suicidal,
are they having suicidal thoughts?
Those are all things that I've learned.
I've learned that it's
important for us as advocates,
as professionals, as loved ones
to remember that we can do
everything in our power,
but we cannot fix people.
I tell people that.
You can't fix other people.
The only thing we can do is
be present, be available,
always let them know that
we're there for them,
try to find resources and
tools to share with them,
educate ourselves so that
we can become more aware.
And I think once we've done all of that,
we have to visit and this
is another auntie part,
we have to forgive ourselves.
I have a really close girlfriend
who lost her son to suicide
about, maybe 25 years ago.
Yeah, 24, 25 years ago.
And ever since then she and
I have been close partners.
We go around and do a lot of
advocating internationally.
We've been to a couple
of different places.
And she shares her story
about losing her son
after losing her first
husband in a car accident.
So she believes that her son's suicide
was related to complicated grief
that he never was able to heal.
So he was six when he lost his dad
and he died by suicide at 15.
And so those are just some
of the different things
that I've learned about
suicide prevention.
But I think the most important thing is,
one of the most important
things that I've learned
is we still don't know enough
about suicide prevention
in black communities specifically
because we don't have
enough research out there.
Now, we know anecdotally,
we know how to have these
conversations in our community.
I want nonprofits and funders, right,
that's part of why we're
so invested in research,
to go out there and do the
work to give us more ideas
about how do we take care of ourselves.
And part of that is
learning how to understand
the relationship between
racism, discrimination,
all the isms, right, of the
phobias that people experience
and suicide.
When you have the weight
of all those things
compounding your depression,
your anxiety, or your trauma,
I think it can be a
really awful perfect storm
that contributes to it.
But we just have not spent enough time
and invested in this country
in getting that knowledge
to be able to help people on the scale
that we would like to.
So that's why with Doug,
what you do is so critical,
Dr. Addy having this
podcast is so critical.
I know what I do,
again, I'm being unapologetic
like the young folk,
what I do is so critical
because we are the ones
who are gonna put a spotlight on this
and show people, right?
So I hope if everybody listens,
that people listen to this, Doug,
what they hear you say is
y'all need to go get some therapists
and bring 'em, like App State,
all these other white school,
bring them therapists to them kids
in the safe place for them.
Stop asking them to go over to CAPS,
Counseling and Psychological Services.
So things like that,
that's what we have to do
to support our young people
and to help prevent suicide.
- Yeah, that's so important.
I mean, so many important aspects
that you've both brought out.
And not easy, like I've
said several times,
but I mean, it's critical.
'Cause like I said, if
we don't talk about it,
that's where things
sit, where they've been,
I'm telling you, to both
of what you're doing
to really move the conversation forward,
move the resources forward.
Just make sure that people know.
So, I mean, it goes back to
that community in isolation too.
And just making sure, Dr.
Alfiee, like you said,
that we're present
and we're willing to
have those conversations.
Other question I usually
like to, oh, go ahead.
I don't know if there's
something else you wanna,
you good, okay.
Also, just like to ask folks
in the midst of all these challenges too,
what gives you hope especially
in the work that you're doing
with the young people?
You've hinted at some of that already,
but we're curious if both of you
kind of elaborate on that piece too.
- That's easy for me.
This right here gives me hope,
knowing that there are
people younger than me
who care about this stuff, who are black,
black, black, blackity black,
who care about this stuff.
That gives me hope.
Because we know that we're not alone.
And there can never be too
many of us doing this work.
So every new foundation
I see, more power to you
because that's more of us to do the work
to reach more people.
Me having being able
to start the foundation
and to fund raise the way
that we were able to do
in the first year, that gives me hope.
And a lot of our funding comes from people
who are not black.
And so it gives me hope
that other people are paying attention
and care and wanna help
our young people of color.
Those two things.
And then finally, what gives me hope
is just young people in general.
Like, just knowing how, again,
they just inhabit their own space
and they know who they are.
And like you said, Dr. Addy,
jumping out of undergrad
or coming right out of,
or being in residency
or graduate school and they're
gonna start their podcast,
they gonna start their own foundation,
that gives me hope because it lets me know
that they are not broken,
especially our kids of color,
by the systems that impact
and weigh on them so heavily.
But the most important thing today
that's given me hope is being
able to be here with you too.
That just gives me all
the hope in the world.
And so more power to both of you.
- Wow, that's mutual.
I can tell you that.
- Yeah, I would say the same points.
The things that give me hope
is just really seeing the
progress with the youth.
You come in, you spend time with them
and then a year later you see
that they're in a better space
than they were when you first met them.
And now they're ready to put some action
behind some of the feelings
and experiences that they have.
And Dr. Alfiee, to one of
the points that you said,
just how many people
gravitate towards a cause
or experience when you may not even know
or they might not even be black or they,
you don't even know why they do it,
but somewhere down the
line they may had a friend
or experience that
they're really trust him
and that's why they
wanna join on the cause.
So just seeing people
share that passion with me
is something that really
helps and gives me hope.
And just seeing that things
are changing day by day,
you just gotta continue to
take it one day at a time.
- That's so good.
Well, it's gonna sound like a cliche,
but I know that both of you
give a lot of people hope,
just in the work that you're doing.
And to be completely honest,
I mean, we talked about this
before we jumped on too,
but how quickly you both were willing
to jump on this podcast too.
I mean, personally, that
gives me a lot of hope,
seeing what you all are doing.
And I feel like in some ways,
and I'm in the place of privilege,
to be able to bring all
these different folks
on to this podcast to kinda amplify
what you all are already doing.
'Cause I mean, you're
already doing the work.
This is just another platform.
It's kinda bringing those pieces together,
and I think to talk about it
in a way that doesn't always get as much,
quote, unquote airplay.
So yeah, I'm deeply
appreciative to both of you.
- Thank you.
- And I think this is gonna go a long way.
I hope our listeners will feel that too
when they listen to this episode.
So any closing pearls of
wisdom from either of you?
You dropped a lot of those already.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- The only thing I would
add is curate your news
and know, I will always
want young people to know,
if you feel like at any
moment nobody cares,
that Doug cares, Dr. Addy
cares, Dr. Alfiee cares,
and you are seen, you are
valued, and you are heard.
We just need you to know that.
- You're never alone.
That's what I was telling.
You're never alone.
You have so many people
that care about you.
And just find a good support
system to put around you.
That way if you're ever struggling,
if you ever have a tough day,
you have some people that can recognize
that you're going through that
and be there to help
you get you through it.
- So good, so good.
Well, I'm indebted to both of you.
Thanks again for jumping on the Addy Hour.
This is gonna bless a lot of folks.
And I know these conversations,
and I'm looking forward just to continuing
to following the work that
you're both doing too.
And hopefully you all can connect
in your overlapping interests too.
I think there's a lot there.
- Absolutely.
It's done, it's done.
Thank you for having us.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
(upbeat lively music)